back and right now the jets have a big
question mark at quarterback
how did what are your thoughts on that
situation not knowing
yeah i mean you know the situation
it is what it is obviously i'm coming in
with my understanding that you know is
the guy and
um you know that doesn't scare me away
at all
you know i've seen sam do great things
and you know i have all the belief in
him and
um you know whichever direction they
decide to go it's it's on me to make
sure that i'm really
um not very convincing explanation
from corey davis that sam is the guy
says i'm coming in with the
understanding that he's the guy but
whatever direction they decide to go
in it's on me and then he was asked a
follow-up question
so they told you that that sam darnold's
gonna be the starting quarterback and
his response was something like yeah
that's my understanding
look they they're not gonna they're not
gonna talk
or anyone else what they're planning on
doing right all that matters to him is
that's the team he's playing for now and
he trusts
that they're gonna have a quarterback at
least as good as sam darnold
ready to go come week one no no no doubt
about it and you know again i think that
there is belief in that jets
organization that sam darnold
can be a good quarterback and lead them
to the playoffs and the promised land
i do and i think they also look at it
from the same you know
the fact that he does fit in the offense
that mike lafleur is going to run and
everything there too
so i i don't you know like we said
before we started
i started evaluating quarterbacks and
doing all that i don't think that's a
wrong move if they
keep sam darnold and and decide to
you know maybe trade the number two pick
away to somebody who is hot on zack
wilson
or you know maybe they take somebody
else at number two i don't know
um it's it's not horrible i just know
you know the way i look at it
zach wilson's got some really really
special attributes to his game
really special that fit that offense
even more
than sam darnold you know like we talked
about with rogers up there with green
bay and matt lefleur so uh
that'll that'll be interesting and
listen i think the the
you'll hear the sam darnold trade talk
and everything start to heat up more
after the jets get to check all their
boxes and get to see
you know the zack wilson pro day and get
to meet him a little bit and bring him
in and do that
to where there'll be a decision made to
go okay this is
we like this guy you know the person
confirmed everything we saw in film
now let's shop sam darnold or they get
done with the process and you know
there's something they don't like about
zack wilson
and they they move on and then they say
okay sam's the guy and does anybody want
the number two pick so that that'll be
interesting too
you know and here here's one thing that
again just draft stuff that bothers me
right
i just narratives one thing i hear with
zach wilson
and people ask me this when i go on
radio well you know he's a rich kid
you know he's you know he okay laissez
faire
fair upbringing yes you know yes but
but my my comment to that would be like
you know
peyton and eli they they weren't poor
okay yeah i think they were kind of rich
chris sims was rich we can go on and on
down the line
that doesn't mean jack diddley squat you
know in a lot of the times with those
type of people
you know if you have a father who's
worked hard and set a good example you
you get to see and go wait that's what i
got to do to be successful i got to be
like dad i see him working and he
he gets after it every day the other
thing that people always take for
granted
in that situation and i'll be the first
to tell you is
i like being able to have money and do
what i want to do
so i was willing to work because i
wanted to live the life that i had grown
up in and wanted to continue to do that
and not have to think about you know
penny pinching and all those type of
things and i think sometimes that gets
overlooked in this situation too
i'm just i'm just glad to know that that
is a
trigger for you i mean criticism of
quarterback prospects because they're
rich
i don't like some of those narratives
like i said where zach wilson
we talk about you know again the
competition and then yet with trey lance
who's also in the first round
conversation competition's not part of
the conversation i don't know why
but that's not and i just don't
understand why some things become
like synonymous with the player and then
the other guy gets a free pass
on the same thing and that's that's
bothers me about the draft process
can i be can i be completely candid
about why this happens yeah tell me
because the the draft nick industry the
people who are
only in this to tell us about the
players
coming out of the draft they get
manipulated they get manipulated by
their sources and the story and the
sources
know that look every team that likes a
guy
wants to spread bad stuff so the guy
falls down the board and they can get
him
and a team that doesn't like a guy will
spread all kind of good stuff because
they want some sucker
to draft the guy before before
uh they are on the board pushing down
someone they want so the people who do
draft and only draft i think
fall victim to that because they are
preyed upon
by scouts who have their agenda
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports